est-ce que tu préfères faire l'amour
avec Carlos tu as acheté gâté Carlos
ou Zaza le chien de Michel Drucker
qu'est-ce que tu préfères Dostoïevski
zoolski ou le whisky
alors imagine maintenant que tu sois
comme ce pauvre je dis la type qui a
écrit les versets sataniques qui est
condamné à mort par l'imam comédie il a
dit faut tuer busy tous les musulmans du
monde te cherche tu imagines tu vois le
tableau et tu décides de te faire
refaire le visage
ce qui serait dommage quand on te voit
d'ailleurs je peux te le dire est-ce que
tu te ferais refaire le visage comme
Denise Fabre comme Evelyne Leclerc ou
comme Marie-France Kubala
20h30 tu remarqueras
je voudrais ressembler à Denis
le plus plaisir à la radio à matin en te
réveillant la fin de l'apartheid la mort
de Pinochet qui TF1 a supprimé le juste
prix
tu préférais être coincé dans
l'ascenseur avec
johanna-heny ou Philippe solaire
Bernard-Henri Lévy
à cause des cheveux du torse la cheville
et tout ça ça va lui faire plaisir alors
ce que tu reproches le plus à Dieu
d'avoir mis sur terre
les impuissants
les homosexuels ou les choses
on y va doucement les impuissants tu as
rien contre les choses d'accord alors
maintenant tu sors un soin dans une
boîte même si c'est pas très Mandel et
puis tu rencontres un mec génial
vraiment c'est tu dis ça y est c'est je
craque c'est le coup de foudre tu
rentres avec lui et tu arrives chez toi
et tu as oublié un truc sur la table de
nuit qu'est-ce que c'est qui t'emmerde
aurait le plus vis-à-vis de ce mec que
tu veux absolument séduire bien entendu
ça serait d'avoir oublié un godemichet
ou mind camp
Agne
je te comprends alors maintenant tu es
obligé c'est un jeu hein tu es obligé de
faire l'amour
obligé tu es obligé tu as un flingue sur
la tempe là tu es obligé tu es
prisonnière tu es obligé de faire
l'amour est-ce que tu préfères faire
l'amour avec Carlos
tu as acheté Carlos
ou Zaza le chien de Michel Drucker
je t'en prie ta maison de disque te
pardonnera jamais de refuser le chien de
Drucker alors Zaza
tu iras loin c'est bien ça va faire
plaisir à Michel Drucker il va être très
content alors maintenant ton petit ami
c'est un petit ami
il a imagine il a des problèmes bon il
arrive pas trop à ça peut arriver sur ça
arrive à tout le monde bon alors
qu'est-ce que tu fais tu discutes en lui
disant comment elle s'appelle tu me
trompes je suis sûr qu'il y en a une
autre première solution deuxième
solution tu lui fais un truc spécial
troisième solution tu te casses
tu te casses
bon alors tu rencontres un mec le mec
génial de tout à l'heure j'ai oublié le
godemichet sur la tête de nuit alors le
mec bon il est super mais il a un
problème il a le hoquet il parle sans
arrêt où il est très cochon qu'est-ce
que c'est qui t'emmerde le moi le hoquet
il arrête pas de parler au lit c'est un
supportable
sans arrêt ou alors il est très très
cochon qu'est-ce que tu préfères
[Rires]
c'est drôle alors maintenant imagine que
tu achètes un perroquet
c'est un Perru t'as pas de perroquet tu
achètes un perroquet un jour avec tous
tes disques et tout a plein sublime
perroquet qui a prendre tout ce qu'on
lui dit tu lui dis une phrase il la
prend est-ce que tu préfères lui apporte
quelle phrase tu lui apprendrais petit
con petit courant est-ce que tu la
prendrais busit tu as oublié de fermer
le gaz
ce qui est important est-ce que tu lui
apprendrais est-ce que le mec a mis sa
capote ou est-ce que tu apprendrais coco
arrête la coco
coucou
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu